ivan melendez's days are heavy
filled with fighting a pandemic that
plunged his community
into despair he rarely stops
except for this his morning prayer
today he's visiting five hospitals in
hidalgo county
where nearly 1200 people have died from
covet 19.
how you doing sir edinburgh regional
medical center has skillfully
turned a corner but no one wants to
tempt fate
i don't want to say this because i'm
going to jinx you but it looks pretty
quiet
when texas reopened they saw a surge in
the sick in this heavily hispanic area
and they had to rapidly adapt this
used to be a conference room but it was
converted into an intensive care unit
one of
five in the hospital and at the height
of the pandemic it was
packed with patients everyone here is
being intubated
and the chance of survival is very slim
this whole room was filled to the brim
of people
everywhere you would see people in body
bags the average length of time was 10
to 11 hours sometimes to get people out
of that stretcher
because the transport people couldn't
come and pick them up
what do you think's behind the
improvement
here our numbers are less because people
are paying more attention there hasn't
been major holidays
people are using their face masks and
the last part which i think is a sad
commentary
is that a lot of our fragile people
myself alone have lost 12 people
in the last month at the nursing homes a
lot of those folks are barely hanging on
they've gone what do you think was the
dynamic that created
such a big problem here so if you're the
number one or the number two
in the entire united states and obesity
number one
diabetes number one access to healthcare
among the lowest forty percent of our
people are underinsured or uninsured
i hate to use cliches but you have a
perfect storm
gustavo ortiz has pneumonia from covidan
he's feeling the financial burden too
what do you say gustavo to those people
who don't believe coronavirus is still a
threat it says he's his testament
that is real and that you know that that
exists that he's suffering from it
were you one of the folks that doubted
it
[Music]
he says he was one of those that doubted
it
the tide of death has started to shift
juan lopez says he's still moving up to
20 bodies a day though
i've been dealing for the past six
months i've been dealing
thousand bodies lots of bodies a
thousand you know i i
lost count where there isn't
death there's fear a shrine now a place
to plea for protection
here faith and family are everything but
living close together
has made many more vulnerable
priscilla garcia lost both her parents
rolando and yolanda
in just four days since they both had
coveted
we didn't get to have a funeral for them
it's really sad because it's not normal
to go through that to not be able to
warn your parents
and then not be able to say goodbye to
them
either because of everything that's
happening it's really bad
how does it feel now being in the home
it's really hard because i have to see
this every day
managing the grieving and the dead
remains a problem
two weeks ago they had 108 covet 19
victims here
now it's 69. it went from
normal business one day to the next day
knocking down walls because we don't
know where we're going to keep everybody
it's just been extremely challenging
what personal toll
has it taken on you it's taken a huge
personal toll you know i was telling my
wife the other day
i didn't sign up to run bodies through a
funeral home i signed up to care for my
community
you know there's a big there's a lot of
people out there that are talking about
first responders right now there's a big
movement last responders
[Music]
today timothy is saying goodbye to his
friend jorge cabrera
a celebrated police officer killed by
covert
everyone's been forced to mourn in a new
way
in a country with more than 184
thousand dead cordelia lynch sky news
hidalgo county texas